sí y melissa lucio llevaba 14 años en el
corredor de la muerte muy poca gente
conocía de su caso hasta que pues hubo
un documental un documental de una
documentalista francesa que pues se puso
este caso en la luz pública el
documental se llama lúcio versus el
estado de texas en este documental pues
la documentalista muestra errores
judiciales errores judiciales y efecto
de este documental que llegó incluso
hasta los oídos de kim kardashian y de
otras personalidades acá en eeuu que se
pronunciaron para que le dieran el
perdón a melissa lúcio entre otros
fallos judiciales pues hay que resaltar
el tema de el interrogatorio que se hizo
inmediatamente después de que declararan
muerta su bebé su niña maria de dos años
la policía los paramédicos le informan a
la policía que hay algo raro porque hay
muchos moretones en el cuerpo de la
menor y pues hay un dolor de cabeza un
golpe en la cabeza que la menor sufrió
de 14 pisos que cayó esta menor y pues
entonces cuando me dije cuando melissa
anuncio habla con los paramédicos y
explica qué fue lo que pasó lo explica
en una casa diferente a donde estaban
donde estaban esa escalera de 14 pisos
donde cayó esa bebé lo que dice los
paramédicos en esa nueva casa que apenas
tenía 23 escaleras es que era imposible
que ese golpe en la cabeza fuera causado
por tres escalones esto escala de forma
que se sale de control se hace el
interrogatorio las autoridades hacen
este recordatorio ese mismo día y ese
mismo día pues está en este
interrogatorio ministra lucio termina
por presiones de las autoridades
diciendo que qué bueno que al hablar
mejor si era culpable pero lo negó casi
cien veces antes de decir esto que
terminó siendo la prueba para que le
dieran la la pena capital